we're now equipped i think with all of
the tools to convert back and forth
between polar and rectangular
coordinates and hopefully you have a
reasonable intuition i mean they're both
just two ways of specifying a point in
two dimensions cartesian you kind of say
how far left and right you go that's the
x coordinate and then the y coordinate
says it tells you how far up and down
you go and you get to a point when you
do polar coordinates the the angle tells
you what direction to point in and then
the r or the you could view it as the
radius tells you how far to walk in that
direction
right so there's two ways to specify a
point in space and as we'll see some
functions are easier to specify or
they're better described in polar
coordinates while other functions are
better described in cartesian
coordinates but before we actually do
functions let's do a couple of a couple
of quick
quick problems
using the tools that we've built let's
say that we're given the polar
coordinate let's say we're given the
polar coordinate 4
comma 150 degrees
and we wanted to convert this to
cartesian coordinates we want to convert
it to x
comma y
so we can just you know our
our first thing that we could do is just
just get an intuition of where this even
is i mean right now i think you're
already at the point where if i give you
an x and y coordinate you already have a
visualization of where that shows up but
polar might be relatively new so let's
try to
let's try to draw it
so
for me when i do polar i like to think
about the angle first so 150 degrees so
if we start at the x axis you see that's
90 degrees all the way around is 180
degrees so this will be 30 degrees away
from
180 so it's going to be in this
direction
right this is 100 and if this angle
right here is 150 degrees
and i do find degrees easier to
visualize than radians
that's i think just because we use that
in everyday life and then so we're
saying okay i'm i've pointed you in this
direction i've pointed you in that
direction how far should you go it says
well you go four units in the 150 degree
direction so you go four units so
i don't know what that'll be i don't
want to do that
so i want to go four units in that
direction so
i will go so i'm just assuming this is
i'm doing a different color
i'm just assuming this is
one two three
four units so that's four 150 degrees so
we want to convert this to cartesian
coordinates and so we already have an
intuition that our x-coordinate should
be some negative number and our
y-coordinate should be some positive
number right and let's see if it all
bears out so what are the tools that we
came up with in the last in the last
video
well we came up with x
is equal to r cosine theta and that just
fell out of sohcahtoa nothing fancy
there and y is equal to
r
sine
theta
so this coordinate x is equal to r
cosine theta so this is going to be let
me write it in a different color
x is r
so now we're doing with cartesian
coordinates r cosine theta so r is 4 so
it's 4
cosine
of 150 degrees
and then the y is
r
which is 4 times sine of 150 degrees
sine of 150 degrees
and now we can get the calculator out
okay
so let's see what's the cosine of 100
well i'll just write it out so 4
times
the cosine of 100 and make sure your
calculator is in degree mode
you don't want to make it think you're
saying 150 radians
so it's minus 3.46 so the x coordinate
is minus 3.46
and what is the y-coordinate it's four
four times
sine of 150 degrees
which is equal to two
which is equal to two and that makes
sense right if we eyeball that looks
about right this looks about you know if
we go
one two three and a little bit more than
three that looks like
minus three point four six and then we
go up one two that looks like about
positive two so our intuition was right
you could either go kind of orient
yourself into 150 degree direction and
then march 4 in that direction or you
could say oh i'm going to go minus 3.46
to the left and 2 up so we've we've just
done a transition from polar to
cartesian coordinates not too bad so now
let's step it up a little bit and
actually convert functions from
cartesian to polar and polar to
cartesian and back and forth
okay so i'm just did a random web search
for problems and i found these
see the first one
they want us to convert this
x squared plus y squared is equal to
four convert this to polar coordinates
right and hopefully you have some
intuition already that this is a circle
right and it's actually even more
obvious when you're doing polar
coordinates so what were the toolkits we
had built we had we had figured out that
x squared
plus y squared is equal to r squared
that was just the pythagorean theorem
we knew that the tangent
of theta was equal to
was equal to the opposite over the
adjacent y over whoops y over x
and we also learned that y is equal to r
sine of theta
and x is equal to r cosine theta
and you can prove all of these just from
sohcahtoa and the pythagorean theorem
but if you had to memorize one thing
going into an exam on polar coordinates
it would be these four equations not
that i'm a big fan i actually don't have
these memorized i always spend literally
the first 10 seconds of the exam writing
these down or reproving them and that
way you'll never forget it but anyway
let's convert this to polar coordinates
well you should already see well we have
an x squared plus y squared and we
already say well x squared plus y
squared is equal to r squared so we can
just rewrite this as r squared
is equal to four
and then you can say oh maybe you know r
is equal to plus or minus 2
right and actually doesn't matter you
could just say r is equal to 2. and what
does that mean actually i think it's
it'll be instructive to say to to graph
this one i wasn't planning on it but i
think it'll be it'll be neat to show you
i mean r equals 2 that's such a simple
equation how can that be a circle
well what is a circle a circle is
something of constant radius around some
point
right so this is saying a constant
radius radius is equal to two so if we
take a distance of
if we so this is
one two so it says no matter what the
angle is right this this function uh
doesn't even involve the angle it says
the radius is constant doesn't matter
what angle i have so if the angle is
zero the radius is two if the angle is i
don't know 30 degrees the radius is
still 2 if the angle is 60 degrees it's
still 2 so the radius is 2 no matter
what and i should probably use the
circle tool so as we go around it
doesn't matter the radius is always
going to be 2.
this distance is always going to be 2 no
matter what direction we're pointed in
and to some degree that's the definition
of a circle so this in a circle in polar
coordinates is actually a lot easier to
write down
radius is equal to two that's a circle
let's do the next one
i'm going to erase
this i'm going to erase this because i
want to reuse this over here
so let me just
black that stuff out
okay
and then
here i go all right the next one they
give us
is
x squared plus y squared is equal to 9
times y over x
squared
already if we do some pattern matching
well x squared plus y squared we know
that's equal to r squared so this is
equal to
r squared is equal to
9 times c y over x that looks suspicious
tangent of theta is equal to y over x so
this is tangent of theta so 9 times
tangent
of theta
squared and maybe we want to take the
square root of both sides
right so r is equal to remember we have
to take the square root of both of these
because we're taking the square root of
the whole both sides so r is equal to we
could say plus or minus 3
tangent
of theta but actually doesn't matter
once again and that happens a lot in
polar coordinates and as you'll see well
you saw it with that case of
actually let me show you what a negative
radius means
just so that you get the intuition why
in that previous example didn't matter
whether i took the radius as -2 or
positive 2. so for any given angle i
just want to give you an intuition of
what theta is of what a negative radius
is if i give you a positive radius we're
going to go in that direction right for
this angle but if i give you a negative
radius we go in the other direction so
this would be a positive radius and this
would be a minus radius you just go
backwards you walk backwards in that
direction
so in that previous example we could say
okay the radius is equal to 2 no matter
what
right so when your angle is in this
direction your radius is equal to 2 or
you could say the radius is always equal
to negative 2
right when you're pointed in this
direction the radius is equal to minus 2
and when you and so it's always going to
be -2 it ends up being the same thing
either way and actually turns out the
same thing for this equation so you
could just say r is equal to 3 tangent
of theta if you're not sure i guess it
doesn't hurt to put the plus or minus
there
next one let me erase this one again
actually i'm almost out of time let me
continue this in the next video